i started working for amazon as business
operations associate as soon as i left
college i wanted to go into a technical
job profile but not in the software
development field
so after a lot of consideration and
research i chose business analysis as
the next destination in my professional
journal i am proud to say that i have
trapped another job at comcast yeah i
will be earning 354 percentage more than
what i was earning at amazon hi i am
santosh pakistan i live in chennai i
have turned my career around with the
alpha synthetic
i have done the post graduation program
in business analysis with purdue
university from simply
i took this course when i was in second
year of my business operations associate
job in retrospect i should have done it
sooner as my life changed for the better
as a result
i even got an offer from flex even
before completing the course where i'm
currently working as a business analyst
i am proud to say that i've trapped
another job at comcast where i'll be
joining as a business analyst shortly
there i'll be earning 354 percentage
more than what i was earning at amazon
so basically in a span of 10 months i've
increased my income by 354 percentage
which i'm happy and excited about
my journey with simply learn was amazing
the trainers were experts in their
respective fields whatever the daughters
was quite simple to understand and
straight forward
even though i was fairly new to this
film it was great to be able to learn on
the weekends as well as for after hope
clearing sessions even before starting
the course i had access to all the
training modules and everything seemed
very easy
so the technical stuffs and also the
tools were very clear could also simply
love
i would like to tell anyone who is
trying to achieve something they want to
motivate themselves and to accept the
reality one cannot grow until is willing
to grow you need to take action rather
than just keep procrastinating so take
the first step today and keep learning